SCP-173. It’s a peculiar statue with a bad
attitude and a penchant for strangulation
and snapping necks, though only if nobody
has maintained unbroken eye contact with it.
Some know it as The Sculpture, some know it as
The Peanut, some know it as probably the most
important anomaly of all, considering it’s the
one that got this whole crazy affair started.
But today we’re here to ask an important
question: Do any of us really know it at all?
After all, its original file is hardly
comprehensive. You might even venture to
say it’s one of the most enigmatic SCPs out there,
despite its popularity, but today, we’re taking a
dive beneath the concrete, rebar, and Krylon-brand
spray paint to give you the real inside scoop
on SCP-173. We’ve broken into the SCP Foundation
Archive and found ten different important files on
this infamous vertebrae vandal, and we’re going to
explore each and every one of them with you today.
As you can expect from the weird and wild
SCP Foundation, they cover possible pasts,
presents, and futures, and some of them will
naturally contradict. But that just gives you
more of an opportunity to immerse yourself and
compare them. We often like to believe that the
real truth is somewhere in between, so make sure
you pay attention to every detail throughout.
So let’s get this show on the road, and explore
our ten documents of interest for SCP-173
in hopes of finally getting the complete
story. And of course...Don’t blink.
Document One: Crunch.
Where better to start than the mind
of the sinister sculpture itself?
“Crunch” gives us an insight into the private
thoughts of this otherwise pretty uncommunicative
monster and reveals a great deal about its
relationship with its favorite activity:
Snapping the necks of anyone
who dares to look away from it.
In Crunch, SCP-173 speaks in very basic, broken,
Rorschach-esque English, saying things like:
“Room dark. People gone. Can move. I happy.
Trapped for years. Kept by men for "research".
Left alone in room, left to scratch at walls.
Left to rot and die unless needed. Specimen for
"research". Trapped by self. Never seen by others,
never spoken. Listen, but never
speak. See, but never seen.
Made of rock when others come. Free when they
not look. Prisoner when they look back. I hate.”
SCP-173 hates and resents its captors
for keeping it confined. In its own mind,
“Crunch” - how it refers to the snapping of its
victims’ neck - is the only thing that gives its
life a sense of meaning. It will continue
to Crunch for as long as it’s contained,
because thanks to the SCP Foundation,
Crunch is all it has left these days.
Document Two: How 173 Got to Site-19.
This semi-origin story is one that fans
of this channel will be familiar with.
While it doesn’t give us an insight into why
this nasty pile of concrete actually exists,
it does inform us why it’s currently our problem.
SCP-173 isn’t actually an anomaly
native to our universe. However,
its native dimension was destroyed
by the beast trapped in SCP-2317:
The Devourer of Worlds. As is standard procedure
for a universe about to experience an XK-Class End
of the World Scenario, the Foundation’s
Department of Extra-Dimensional Affairs
swooped in and collected all the valuable
anomalies before the world went down the tube.
One of these was, of course, SCP-173, which was
vacated to Site-19 in our dimension in 1993.
Do you think we would have been better
off if we just left him for the devourer
of worlds to take care of? Let us know what
you think about that down in the comments.
Document Three: The Black Moon.
Sometimes, you can be your own worst enemy.
If the file on SCP-001, The Black Moon,
is to be believed, the SCP Foundation may actually
be behind the creation of this ornery objet d'art
- though in the Foundation’s defense, it was in
service of potentially fighting off a far more
deadly foe, the ominous extra-dimensional
being known only as the Black Moon.
One attempt to stop the Black
Moon from destroying the universe
was known as the KEY Project, which involved
creating a number of items linked to the Black
Moon via conceptual engineering that
would hopefully nullify its effects.
The objects needed the following qualities:
An inability to act while under observation,
a hostility towards human life, and the capacity
to end conscious life if given the opportunity.
Those three descriptors fit SCP-173 to a tee, and
it was considered the project’s greatest success.
However, it sadly wasn’t enough to actually
stop the horrific rampage of the Black Moon.
The researcher managing the case, Dr. Moto,
was so ashamed by the failure that he willingly
entered SCP-173’s containment chamber,
and got his neck snapped in the process.
Document Four: Conclusions
RE: D-173-2263 Incident.
This document finds its origins in
the video analysis of a Foundation
researcher with an incredibly powerful
name: Dr. Delano Smascher. Dr. Smascher
had closely observed video footage of SCP-173
killing several members of D-Class personnel
and began formulating a new theory about
how 173 actually killed its victims.
Dr. Smascher theorized, after all, that
something with arms as short as SCP-173
and no opposable digits would have trouble
effectively strangling or snapping human necks.
According to Dr. Smascher’s observations,
SCP-173 doesn’t actually make any physical
contact with its victims. Instead, the victims
feel oddly compelled to look at the creature
if ever nothing is looking at it. Their eyes
will snap open, and their heads will twist
at any angle they need to in order to look
at the creature in the eyes. It’s the sheer
force of this sudden change that often leads to
snapped necks and bruised faces for the victims,
not the Sculpture itself physically causing
the damage. If Dr. Smascher is to be believed,
the Sculpture is deadly purely because it simply
demands to be looked at by somebody at all times.
Document Five: Anniversary.
This brings us nicely to our
next document: Anniversary,
positing a different theory for
the mysterious creation of SCP-173.
This comes from the perspective of said possible
creator, an anomalous entity that we’ll call
The Artist. Much like the unfortunate
Dr. Moto, The Artist, an intelligent
being that can seemingly become invisible and
intangible at will, considered SCP-173 to be
its finest creation. It viewed SCP-173 as a
perfect representation of humanity: It does
nothing but bleed and defecate, and if anyone
refuses to pay attention to it, it kills them.
It was a perfect symbol of The Artist’s contempt
for humanity. It even easily snuck into Site-19 to
visit SCP-173 on the anniversary of its creation
and found the Foundation’s lack of appreciation
for this fine creation. As an act of revenge for
keeping his creation locked up and out of sight
for so long, he gave the sculpture permission,
just once, to kill someone who looked away, even
if others were still looking at it. For SCP-173,
this would be considered a wonderful little treat.
Document Six: Her Masterpiece.
This next document, known as “Her Masterpiece”,
suggests that SCP-173 was created by a very
different kind of artist. While this potential
creator of SCP-173 was somehow able to produce
an anomaly, she was not anomalous herself,
just motivated by rage and revenge. She’d been
pregnant in the past but lost the baby due to the
actions of a man whom she considered her greatest
enemy. She vowed to make art from his demise.
The woman murdered her enemy with a baseball
bat, before using concrete and rebar to build
SCP-173 around him, almost as a way to mock
her fallen foe. However, like something out
of a horror movie, this act of murderous
creation somehow imbued SCP-173 with life.
When this spiteful artist had eventually
finished the creation and started to walk away,
it claimed her as its first victim. The last
thing she remembered hearing was the sound of
concrete scraping against the ground, and then
a nasty crunch, before everything went dark...
Document Seven: RE: The Statue.
From one tragedy to another. The document
“RE: The Statue” shows the journey of
Researcher Marcus Silburn from idealistic
young employee to full-on mental breakdown
after trying and failing to gain control
of SCP-173. He entered the SCP-173 project
with bright eyes and big ideas about how to
contain the Sculpture, suggesting that the
human element be removed entirely in order
to reduce risk to Foundation personnel.
He proposed ideas like introducing a
sprinkler and drainage system to the chamber
and using a sentient AI and remote viewing
technology to keep SCP-173 immobilized.
However, he was then enlightened to some
frustrating and frightening facts about SCP-173:
In the absence of actual present human
observation, the same build-up of feces and
blood that the creature somehow excretes builds up
in any technology used to control or contain it.
It destroys the circuit boards of AIs,
takes flying camera drones out of the sky,
and even degrades the locks on its chamber
doors, leading to the brutal death of a
janitor in the hall. Researcher Silburn
advanced far enough through the ranks of
the Foundation to be in direct communication
with Dr. Jack Bright, the Director of Site-19.
After his final attempt at containing the creature
without direct human observation resulted in
a containment breach and the death of twelve
people, Silburn was moved off the SCP-173 case
after breaking down and begging for permission
to terminate the anomaly. Permission was denied.
Dr. Bright closed the document with a note
to a member of the O5 Council reading,
“It can be surmised that our
conclusion was correct- the object,
for whatever reason, desires or requires
human attention, and will not be denied it.”
Document Eight: A Chance At Freedom.
We once again return to the
direct perspective of SCP-173,
but this differs vastly from the perspective of
SCP-173’s inner monologue presented in Crunch.
According to the document
entitled A Chance At Freedom,
SCP-173 was actually an incredibly intelligent
agent of espionage sent from another dimension
along with its unknown cadet, though the
cadet is heavily implied to be SCP-096.
This piece details a containment
breach from SCP-173’s perspective,
as it is shown looking down on humanity and its
primitive technology. It laments the fact that
it lost its weapon during the interdimensional
transfer, and seethes that if it still had its
weapon, this all would have played out very
differently. Despite conceding that the fact
it underestimated the humans was the main reason
it ended up in containment, it spends the majority
of the document touting its own superiority,
until one of SCP-131 - The Eye Bots - turned
up and froze it in place. The degree to which
SCP-173 hates the Eye Bots cannot be overstated.
Document Nine: Experiences with SCP-682.
Of course, no “full story” video on SCP-173 would
be complete without a discussion of the SCP-682
cross tests. A number of researchers, though
particularly the very persistent Dr. Carlson,
decided to use SCP-173 in various manners in hopes
of finally doing in that damn lizard. In their
first engagement, 682 seemed rightfully frightened
of 173, and when a sniper shot its eyes out, 173
immediately snapped its neck. Of course, it grew
back a series of sniper-proof eyes not long after.
Someone next suggested SCP-173 being sent in
with a picture of SCP-096 taped to its chest,
though this was rejected as being a ridiculous
and incredibly dangerous idea to everyone.
The researchers then went after SCP-682 with
high precision blades, cutting it into pieces,
each of which became autonomously dangerous
entities. SCP-173 then began to murder each
of these blobs of mutated tissue, until it was
stopped when a D-Class was sent in to stare at it,
while the rest of 682 regenerated. SCP-173 was
transported back to its cell, but there was a
brief power outage during transit, leading SCP-173
to kill a number of the staff transporting it.
This test was still considered
a step in the right direction.
After SCP-682 was once again
shrunk by a different anomaly,
SCP-173 was released into its chamber. At first,
it appeared that 173 had actually killed SCP-682,
but a week later it returned, having reconstituted
itself from matter that had been splattered
on SCP-173 after it’d been brutalized.
Making this test, once again, a failure.
Dr. Carlson requested the resources to conduct
one more cross-test, but this request was
denied. A member of the O5 Council affixed a
request, simply saying, “Stop it, Carlson.”
Document Ten: Revised Entry.
Oh...that time SCP-173 literally caused an
XK-Class End of the World Scenario. In the
document Revised Entry, we get a frightening
glimpse into a possible future world,
where SCP-173 develops a terrifying new
anomalous ability: Multiplication. We
don’t know exactly how it happened,
but here, the Sculpture somehow developed
the ability to make exact copies of itself.
And what’s more, every time one of these
copies is produced, the collective SCP-173
hive mind gets stronger. Allowing them to think
tactically, and slowly wipe out North America,
even destroying any potential
Foundation countermeasures,
then ripping and snapping through
anyone or anything that dared oppose.
In the end, the world decided to take the
nuclear option - literally - and blow away
North America with a nuclear bombardment in
order to stop the SCP-173 army from spreading
to the rest of the world and killing everyone.
However, this attempt didn’t actually work,
as SCP-173s were spotted in Wales, over in the
UK, leading to a second nuclear bombardment.
It continued like this until there were no human
beings left to push the big red button anymore,
and only the endless legions of SCP-173 remained.
There is one bright side to this
otherwise pretty bleak situation, though:
A group of around 150 SCP-173s ganged up on
SCP-682 and tore it to shreds. Somewhere
out there, Dr. Carlson is probably smiling.
Now go check out “SCP-173 Origin
Story - How 173 Got to Site-19” and
“The Eye Pods - SCP-131” for more tales involving
the SCP Foundation’s most psychopathic statue!